PROFESSOR: The textbook
itself is a good introduction
for literacy, OK.
But I felt that the-- except for
the first month of this course,
they have to cram 250
characters-- it's hard.
But after that, I think
the pace slowed down a lot,
and I think they
have huge potential,
because the funny things--
teaching heritage learners
is to discover their potential.
Because for regular students,
they only have this much.
They cannot know beyond
what they don't know,
because they learn
everything from you.
But for heritage learners,
it's very different.
They have this
foundation-- this much.
You don't know each person.
So they might know the words.
They just cannot simultaneously
or like naturally think
of, but they heard
this word before.
So for that, it's
their potential.
They have the potential.
So once you discover
their potential,
they can go really fast.
So what I'd like to
change is I'm going to,
in addition to this
textbook, because it's
important for the student
to have a foundation.
Because if they have a
book, they feel much better.
There's certain things
they can control.
I don't want to give
them-- for a higher level,
we start giving them
individual articles.
For the Streamlined III
or IV, they can handle it.
But for the
beginner, they can't.
They want to have a book.
But in addition to
this book, I want
to add more text
relevant to the topics
to the books, which I
did actually last term.
I added two actual
texts talking about how
to address people in Chinese.
And these are considered
more like authentic material,
and they learn a lot.
And it echoes what they
know about Chinese.
They don't talk about
in their textbook,
because this is a newer text
just recently published.
And I think I will do that more,
add that more into the course.
It's two textbooks.
It's called Modern
Readers, and each book
has different
levels of the text.
So I use the text
according to their levels.
So for the Chinese
107, Streamlined I,
I use the one talking
about addressing
people, which is their level.
Because this is a dialogue.
For the Streamlined II, I start
using social media-- talking
about personal page,
talking about-- basically
you want to go on a trip.
You go online and find
people put the blog.
You know, the Chinese, they
put blog and say what you
need to do before these things.
It's authentic material.
Yeah, so I like
to add those more,
because it's relevant
to their life.
And these old books are
good at learning characters,
but not really--
like they said, well,
it's good to learn Chinese
cultures, but it's so old.
They always say, it's so old.
I can't imagine those days.
Why do we have to do this?
I said I know, but
you know, the topic
is just-- it's out of date.
But a good part is it's a
foundation for them to learn.
Like sometimes I joke with them.
I said, just learn
the characters.
It's good for you.
[LAUGHING]
So I think I would like to
not get rid of the textbook
completely, because I think
they will feel panicky,
because there's no textbook.
They don't know what's
next they need to do.
Is have a textbook that has
something they can always
refer to, and then
add more and add
more of these so-called
authentic material.